crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
you ain't gotta ask me cuz you could
trust that every to see you already
don't though
Orion's fake moussaka star Joe go above
pound cook goes better than most
Jay Larson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we don't we
can't fault the crab feast
welcome back to the crab feast y'all now
the Tuesday
don't cry fees for that ass good to see
a Jay Larson comedy sickle cell first
non touching pitch touch of all-time
that was hard today ain't anything
what's up everybody Jay Larson ear Jay
Larson call me calm Jay Larson comedy
and all social media some upcoming dates
may 28th through the 31st I'll be at the
Laughing Skull lounge in Atlanta and
then June 4th through the 6th I'll be a
comics comedy club at Foxwoods casino in
Connecticut would love to see you guys
out at any of those shows as always
sickle cell Ryan Sickler on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook Ryan Sickler comm
you can also check out me any short
videos on youtube.com backslash are
Sickler a MARSOC loner I think there was
another problem with this my youtube
channel man San Francisco I'm coming to
the punchline June 24th June 24th
one night only I'll be at the San
Francisco punchline I want to see the
Bay Area fee stirs I know there's a lot
of you up their ticket links are on my
website Ryan Sickler calm and the crab
feast calm merch that you know what
thank you to all you who buy it and rock
that [ __ ] you guys are seriously the
best and the Amazon is a huge help we do
have a new premium episode up the
episode from South by Southwest is
available on iTunes and now Gumroad with
Michael Showalter Glenn wool and
Hannibal bars super fun episode first
time I think we ever had three guests on
I believe that yeah a lot of fun with
the three of those guys and nice to have
a some diversity and what each guys
talking about you know right and as
always it's only a dollar ninety-nine
and go to the crab feast calm and click
the premium episode links everything's
right there for you those original
premium apps are still on CD baby but
Gumroad
allows us to do more we're gonna take
advantage of that so like to see you
guys lighting up to Facebook Fanpage the
iTunes page all things comedy you can
use our link there on SoundCloud
stitcher and just dining is
tonight I'm excited about this episode
we've been trying for a long time to
chat Vegas combat baby he gave you look
over game of the roof over Vegas calm
back once again you guys know the deal
man
with a little help from our friends of
Vegas comm you can save more money
listeners have saved real money at Vegas
comm with this exclusive offer 84 off
the Bellagio 90 off at Caesars a hundred
off Cirque de Soleil I think it's a
Zara's man as it say's are 10% off of
everything excluding air and hotel
packages it's the only way to book vase
you know they have the drop watch tool
so if you find something cheaper that's
coming back to you you won't get outdone
these are the people that know Vegas
they live there they work there they
know everyone to know you get a best
price guarantee after you've paid it's
it's a no-brainer
headliner shows towards attractions go
to Vegas calm right now click on the
microphone in the top right corner and
enter our code crab feast to receive an
extra 10% off everything but air hotel
packages that's Vegas calm click on the
microphone and get your bonus savings by
using our code crab feast book today
ladies and gentlemen we are extremely
excited for our guests been trying to
get him on for a while but he writes and
brags about it often please look for the
first time the crab feast mr. Dave
Anthony crazed am Anthony thanks I could
barely make it down here cuz I was
writing but uh I got to know how long
have we like every time I hit you up
like can't do it dude boys yeah well
Maron was is a pretty time-consuming job
I can't imagine our schedule is insane
and he is and he's insane but the
schedule is insane and and so it just
takes a lot of time and I act on it too
so it's a good you know Jesus all right
all right sorry what else you it's hard
man I don't know if you guys are right
not a show and on one that's on
television but it's hard man Jay you're
on every episode no so your recurring on
every I'm recurring yeah yeah you could
I mean you'd know that if you if you
watch I guess if you watched it okay
well before we get into this one
you tell everyone where they knew it and
where they can find you social media
social media i television by the way you
guys are one of the only podcasts do
this thank you really yeah no one else
does more yeah the ones they've been on
don't do it either and at the very end
if they remember like oh wait a second
yeah last eight seconds yeah you know
what it is I mean one we love promoting
other comedians and two I think our fans
enjoy it you know they want to interact
with you especially if you have good
we'll see how the podcast goes yeah
that's my boy I'll let you know
yes I'm at Dave Anthony on Twitter I
wouldn't simple with it do you guys have
your names as your Twitter handle yes
because people they don't do that
they're like I'm I'm corned corned beef
you're like really cuz your name is Alex
what about using that one but then you
find out that there's an Alex like
powers in you know like Kitty Hawk North
Carolina who's you know yeah but you're
normally down funnier than that guy I'm
surprised you got Dave Anthony I know
man and I came in late to the game yeah
that's going on Twitter get in Twitter
get in Twitter and I was like I don't
want to do tour finally couple years and
I got in I got it yeah see I got Jay
Larson comedy because I couldn't get JLo
so I think I have I don't I never use
Instagram but I think I have Dave
Anthony comedy on Instagram but I'm not
sure I don't something like that on
Facebook isn't it yeah it's I got my
personal as Ryan Sickler but somehow
like a fan page that's because you can
have it on Facebook you can have
multiple so just Twitter you can you can
have they can be 14,000 Ryan Sickler
'he's on in facebook but on twitter goes
by the handle you know what I mean just
one uno so someone else has someone
someone else has their learn like Texas
who has eaten mail me before and said
there can only be one of us and we went
blah or that's weird
Lord I mean it's like a Highlander
situation at that point you gotta go
take a dude out I do definitely take
that Ryan Sickler Texas out G Google and
I'll get miles when I fly down and come
back I'm miles
do you get Google Alert I don't well
that terrifies me I don't know anything
about what people are saying about me
here
oh I don't get them like I don't get
them super tight I don't know why I only
get ones that like a broad like if
something gets published or whatever and
I just like to see but then I get it for
like Jay Larson CEO of Industrial and
see how the other Jarrett Owen yeah well
there's one there was one of this one
Dave Anthony a follow-on he wrote to was
one that writes for The AV Club or he
did I think he quit and then then the
guy is like a sketch guy out in New York
I was like I'll follow you
I'll see what you're up to he goes with
David Anthony isn't too formal though
cuz you have David out of here yeah Dave
Matt well good I would have gone I would
have gone to I would have gone Dave
underscore Anthony come on man keep it
quite Anthony Dave be friend also go
that way well yeah you could do either
one I'm seeing a lot of people learn a
lot of things about Twitter right now
and I'm I'm glad I'm here to dispense
the advice but there's different handles
you can use you guys you just got back
from Melbourne huh yeah I was in
Melbourne if they get really mad when
you say Melbourne by the way it's
Melbourne what'd I say
you said you pronounced it as you used
all the words and letters a Melbourne
now would have said Mel born yeah you
use all the letters in the word and they
don't do that they like to pretend like
a lot of letters don't exist and they
call it they call it Melbourne alright I
get it
I mean they do that back in
Massachusetts to with yeah words you
know I mean war Chesters yeah try
reading that off the page so uh with I
went to yeah I went to Melanie did one
man show down there which I might
releases an album I haven't decided yet
but I recorded it just in case
well based on the reviews I saw dude I
probably holed up talking about golden
right yeah I hear it somebody somebody
reviewer asked me for a pass came to my
show he's one of the better shows and
then and then reviewed me and it wasn't
a really good review and then sent the
review to me and I'm sorry what this is
like a this is like you want to fight
right now like you want to have a
personal I just I ignored it I was like
I
can't I don't know what's happening
right now but a reviewer sent me the
reveal and it was like yeah it was
alright I got a free ticket but it was
alright so what is your what made you
want to do a one-man show what brought
it about um I got a little tired of
doing sort of the American style comedy
which is kind of talking about nothing a
lot yeah and I want to talk about
something that was a little more
important to me or had a little more
sort of juice to it and I couldn't do it
I tried to do the stuff here because
it's about my dad and how I was really
angry kid and so uh telling me well
you're on the right pocket yeah I did
not have a good upbringing and and so
it's about the anger and all that and
all that stuff and I'm like an angry guy
yeah [ __ ] yeah well welcome home yeah
see brother Ryan yeah so yeah so I tried
it here and I could never do in the
States and I went down there to do a
podcast and I saw some shows and was
like oh you can do a different thing
here so I did it and it was it was I
don't know man it was uh I've never
liked one-man shows the American style
where he you know 45 minutes and you try
to make the audience cry you know and
and then everyone cries and then you
pull out of it now I just wanted to do
something that was funny and and was
real and it worked it was cool probably
the best thing I think I've ever done
very cool which is a weird thing for me
to say because I usually hate what I do
yeah yeah yeah so yeah so I did that and
I got to they put me on TV down there
after couple weeks they asked me to do a
TV gig which is cool so yeah it was nice
it was nicely run you stand up on that
giggly prize yeah yeah I did proper
standup seven minutes set that's great
yeah it's gonna run I don't know that
comedy channel in July or something so
like man it's weird I have a career down
there I have like I get stopped on the
street
we have Australian fans to hit us up all
the time or by Mert they're great yeah
I'm sure I would think
this podcast would they would really
like it down there they they're really
in a radio and
and the stories thing they get into for
some reason yeah they keep it honest we
need to come down and do a show there so
I you would be surprised at how it's not
like America man they just I don't know
what the difference is but they get
really into podcasts and they treat you
very kindly no maybe I'll move the
Australian still smell sell snow cones
yes no come sickle cells thinking about
moving by just wrapping it all up I mean
they're ready for snow cones aren't you
are you all straight I'll hit me up let
me let us know call them snowballs where
I come from
do they really yes I don't know
Baltimore and New Orleans or snowballs
everywhere else is snow cone I don't
know if I agree with that but it's snow
cones
it's snowball its snow cones it's not
ball if it was a ball they just hand you
a ball I'd say they do put it they round
it into a ball okay but then when they
put it in a cus that refers about so
what are we talking about snow cones
she's not coming and who doesn't right
cone okay so this is no cup it's a snow
Cup that you get but it's no topping on
it why would I do that because that's
what a snow ball is now you're saying
now you throw it at the cops as they
drive by I'll make you see a snowball
burst to get that side of a speeding car
you know where they may have the best
it's Hawaii cuz they do with ice cream
and then I well that's the wait they
have us the guy in Baltimore has one you
do one guy who spells it there's a
Hawaiian snowball stand there you go I
snow Eddie's Hawaiian well you have the
option so it's like vanilla ice cream in
the bottom then the ice then you pick
your flavor and then you can top it with
like marshmallow and okay it's not snow
cones no football no you have a view
you're making a full dessert and you're
calling it you're using a false name
it's not a snowball at that point it's
ice cream and whipped cream and it's all
kinds of stuff snowballs at the ball
it's right you don't want to argue about
anything Baltimore it just don't know I
get I get I get what he's saying
I'm a there's riots everybody I'm just
trying to tell them it's wrong that's
all there thanks Dave you're welcome man
I appreciate it you know what I think
that it's time for a guy like me who
came from a very white place to tell
people from Baltimore that they're wrong
yeah it hasn't been happenin what having
enough going on at all
where's that white place Marin County
Marin County
maybe the widest I was gonna say very
white up there aw dude no I we had we
had in my in my elementary school we had
a half a kid who was half black that was
as close as we got one kid one kid did
he like stand up for two and like own
the [ __ ] out of it no no no you kidding
me no his white half was like dude we're
gonna run this just relax dude don't let
it out no one's gonna notice it's just
us I was like growing up up there I mean
it's really secluded and rich and white
so no wonder why you to tough upbringing
yeah it was really hard it was it was
pretty it was pretty easy I mean from
that sense but my dad was a drunk and my
mom was kind of airheaded was he a rich
drunk no he wasn't indistinct they got
rich he can get away the guy well
whatever's got cash yeah we were like
the poor family with the like everyone's
and matches and the paint's peeling off
our house oh we were like that do
[ __ ] yards all growing up yeah oh
yeah yeah all that [ __ ] no one came to
work on our yard higher mite from from
from one day 18 when no one came to work
on our yard that was man they did the
neighbors on the other side just when
they came and just sliced all the shrubs
and like half
why don't you know 13 you know how to
use a football I didn't know any better
man I was just growing up in it and I
just thought that's what you do you just
let this [ __ ] go crazy and you price see
you started to own it more so than that
half black kid you were like you know
what I'm gonna be the little the poor
kid with the drunk dad I have black
family drove by I was like look right
here see these hey stay away from the
auntie in these scary anybody with the
first last name uh-uh-uh
I did I did try I remember one time I
went out and I tried to clean up that
yard I tried to fix it up a little bit
how'd it go I was it was just a
never-ending battle it was just no way
it was it just you your brothers and
sisters I had a sister younger older two
years older two years older she's not
and we worked we didn't get along
because we grew up in that sort of
situation I think you'd get really tight
or you just kind of go I'm gonna do my
own thing and survive yeah you know the
other side of the grassman yeah that's a
lot of grass oh man so were you like
when you involve in the arts as a kid
were you doing that what was your escape
okay so how's it so I was an anger kid I
got angry why why were you his dad used
to beat the [ __ ] up and knock his mother
around
no the only ball once but that's because
I call my mom a [ __ ] so totally we're
gonna talk about this I was [ __ ] up
man by the time I think no but by the
time I hit like 10 12 I was just out of
control like I was just gone
was your mother a [ __ ] no she was just
but day I want to go see the Rolling
Stones and I was 14 and she was like
you're not going to see the Rolling
Stones and I go but I'm going with these
guys and they're older and she goes
that's exactly why I don't want you
going with those guys because those guys
were pot heads yeah and we were gonna do
blow so so I go you [ __ ] and I run out
of the house and I'm running and my
parents are divorced at this point my
yeah my diagraph like an open field
if we Lawrence Taylor comes out I didn't
see you late in the grass I wasn't
laying out stands like corn man so I
they were both sitting there and I
called her I go you lot and I ran out of
the house and I'm running and I think
I'm fine I think I'm just running away
and it looked behind me and I see my dad
and he's determined look on his face
like I haven't seen before drinks thrown
his hands bill it not spill the whiskey
you can hear that you can hear the ice
tinkling nothing is spilling he's
getting closed and he and he chases me
down and I run up this hill and he just
tackles me like he said and just starts
popping me a few times just kind of ow
right up I don't think he me in the face
ribs gave me some body action body both
in the background like your head all G
here is on the mouth by Italian and I
have a kid now I don't I don't know what
I do if he call my weight that's what
you'd snap yeah I wish a boy or a girl
I've got a boy five years of almost 600
yeah yeah I got a 14 month old boy
Ryan's a six almost seven little almost
seven months I didn't know you guys
haven't talked about together dude yeah
yeah nice what so why the anger where to
come from
I was completely neglected man it was
just like I didn't exist
like they just my dad especially it was
just like so they were what each did
their own thing yeah basically we're
divorced yeah they were divorced one
thing they had in common was that
happened when they were divorced where
the hell was he just over he he came
over for the conversation about me not
being able go to the car right so did he
live nearby
like three miles away okay so nearby
yeah and how often would you see him in
the week I'd see him every Sunday every
Sunday yeah I'd go over his house and be
ignored that's so [ __ ] up three miles
away you'd never it was never like hey
do you want to ride your bike your dad's
and do your homework over there son well
he come he come to any sporting event I
had that was about it nobody I didn't
want to go over there and and I don't
think he wanted me to go over there yes
Lee now did you like were you doing arts
were you doing like music or anything
like that alright so when I got really
angry I was also I always always a
creative kid and so I wrote a play such
write to play with his anger let's get
the hit in the [ __ ] heavy bag in the
garage this guy's right right no use
[ __ ] right this right here
alright pentameter two watches so you
have a [ __ ] angry hi yeah but
what smiley care gives ass kicked right
here alright so you had the anger and
and so I had I was real quick so you're
living with your mom Monday to Saturday
also being neglected for whatever blow
juice like just cocktail right we just
come out I would come on the orange
peacocks all over the all over the floor
clean path to the door you know what I
got to deal with when I get out there in
the lawn
open your door and just dicks just push
all the midgets roll down
so yeah what was for deal why was she
neglecting you well she had been also
coincident amazed by very abusive sort
of alcoholic parents so yeah exactly
what she picked my dad so she was just
kind of checked out for the most part
and she also didn't know what to do with
me because I was just like you couldn't
you couldn't control me no matter what
she tried to do I was like no then I
just take off for a night and come back
and and were you getting like when you
say that were you just them or were you
getting arrested like were you I got
arrested writing write plays we'd go out
we'd write plays up in the hills poetry
slams I was just I was I started
drinking a lot when I was like 12
yeah first time gonna blow I was 14 what
yeah I started you know that's that's
because Marin County is also because
it's a wealthy they're just drugs
everywhere and kids could just go get it
from their parents - like when I did
blow we never bought it we we started
buy it after a while but for the most
part we just go whose dad's got a thing
and people go and just take a scoop a
blow out of a jar yes that's kind of how
we were living so it was just everywhere
so we just started doing it now because
you have pores that you have to go last
I found out my dad was smoking pot
because the my friend's mother was
selling it to him
he ratted them out yeah and then she
because we were getting pot from her
Stephanie and she's like by the way my
mom Stephanie what all right I want to
say powers but that's not that's not her
that's a that's a person an actress and
I remember Prue got it Stephanie Peru
you know what man we did our research I
just
I'm back with your acid evidence Katie
all right so he's smoking weed
Stephanie sold it to him I mean we were
at Stephanie and the little gang was in
eighth grade we're doing like quaaludes
and yeah it was crazy
that's we get good grades or what was
going on there no I mean I got good
grades up and toss as a freshman and
then that all just went away pretty
quick yeah I just my wife just pulled I
had my report cards in this box and she
pulled out his box and she's looking at
their poker and she's like holy [ __ ] how
did you get in you like I had one one
quarter I had all FS and a see what was
the CM bro good job check out this
birdcage hilarious thing in his corner
show right now that lady's thing as I
dig in an F in my English literature
class because I just stole I just stole
someone else's story up someone else's
play form anger man yeah why not
so your mom was she work full time she
was a hairdresser yeah
my god did your living a [ __ ] Bon
Jovi song pretty much I just found that
Bon Jovi gets out of paying his taxes at
his mansion by having bees and then he
declares it as a farm and he doesn't pay
any taxes good call they actually
pollinating though do they have to tell
you something what did they do it what
does proof I love the idea though you
can't tell me it's not a farm if I tell
you have a bee farm one flies by Blake
place fools I got right there man about
a thousand more because I'm a TFR man it
could be anywhere what if you went there
and the bees were like shoveling [ __ ]
like dick we ain't no pollinated bees
what sorry guy we work in the garden
with our hands so what will you get into
besides drugs you
playing sports to try McKee I'd like you
I played sports until I was until I was
about just 16 and then I stopped that
completely
yeah with sports and and drinking and
carrying on but like when you write in
plays like were you legitimately writing
like I sit down when I start when I was
really young I wanted to be a stand-up
when I was like five because I used to
watch comics on TV because I as a fight
what what kid from like five to ten
didn't get to stay up until after sadden
our live was over to watch evening at
the improv I just got to do whatever I
wanted so I would just be up at like
1:30 watching uni the improv and I was
like seven so it's crazy it's crazy
existence it was a house - not a trailer
in case you're asking is an actual house
okay cool
yeah you said most trailers don't have
long they're just on proper yeah that's
true
so uh so yeah it was just me doing
whatever I want which is a crazy thought
like I remember leaving the house every
day I'm yelling at my mom and slamming
the door like it was just
I broke the door in half once slamming
it the front door of my home which which
half like up down aside was right up up
and down snapped it right down the
middle that's a good eye I actually did
the same my mother not a nice person
my brother she's all right we're okay
she loved you we had a screen door yeah
and my brother she had locked at one
time we couldn't get into my brother
peeled the rubber out of the screen
reached in unlocked it and then sealed
it back on Oh beautiful half-ass you
know what I mean like just good as you
could but whatever it was fine
so I knew he did that because he told me
did that and I was standing next to him
when he did that but then one day she
came home and I did that same thing and
just started just going off on me tell
me how it's broken I'm gonna have to pay
for it he'd never done that blah blah
blah I just sat there and I lost my [ __ ]
and I pulled the screen out of that
[ __ ] door and I bent it over my leg
like four times in front of one of my
friends I set it on the ground I said
now it's broken
now I'm gonna pay for it
you were six you still [ __ ] toasty
penalizing huh you remember that I liked
ya when I grabbed the squeeze like God I
was a good did you pay yeah I bought a
big screen it was worth like $20 yeah
they're not that much money but still
adores more expensive lures more I
didn't have to Pell a lot more I wasn't
gonna pay for that what how they gonna
make me crazy
I had a job and I made tons of money
what were you doing I was I was working
at a when I when I hit 15 I started
working at this little tiny grocery
store independent grocery store I was
making about 300 bucks a week in high
school damn
for high school grand a week yeah it was
crazy the amount of money I was making
so I was then on top of that I had money
to do whatever I wanted yeah
so it was just nuts did you get a car I
didn't know well I didn't get a car my
parents wouldn't let me get a license
because you're just a [ __ ] yeah they
were like you got it they were like you
got to pay for insurance on your own and
and you got to buy the car and we don't
want you to have a license and all this
stuff so when I hit 18 I know when I was
17 I bought a car and you have your
license then no I just sat on it I had
it around the corner and they just drive
it so for a year every year I didn't
have a license it was a Chevy Malibu so
you had a Malibu sitting around the
corner and would just hop it would just
Park it in the street somewhere yeah it
was just parked around the corner on a
run now with the registered and stuff
well the last guy had registered it I
don't think I registered it I think it
was registered I don't the other guy's
registration and I just drove it for a
while um never got pulled over and
that's amazing yeah it was crazy but
that also made me follow the rules of
the road like I never want to get pulled
over so it was just like three second
lane change three second lane change
that was crazy yeah that's amazing I
mean now that you look back where do you
think all the anger came from do you
think you would have been angry had your
parents stayed together and you were
rich because obviously you're upset
about not having a lot of money I can
see that's something that you can yeah
yeah it was that deal to you that was a
big deal because everyone else was
fairly wealthy that was around me but
no it was the thing that the thing that
got me was I just got nothing from my
dad yeah like no affection no like life
yeah yeah yeah I feel like that tackle
might have been the closest you got to a
hug thanks dad
bleeding from my lip [ __ ] crazy blue on
that lip yeah that was the I would say
that was the main thing that my parents
just were like absent and so when that
happens you just you just get sad and
then you get you don't wanna be sad
after a while and they just turn it at
ball erasure you know I had this I mean
I had a lot of anger too as a kid I
would like everyone one time like nobody
would come out back like we got back
from some of my parents are divorced so
I wouldn't see my dad and like I'm like
someone come on back play with me and
they're like all right we'll meet you
out there and no one came up back
because I go to the back door and I'm
knocking on it no will come the door so
I just punch my hand through the window
and like oh please yourself oh oh yeah I
got one two four scars on my hand and
wrist from that my mom's got to take me
emergency room another hand and blood
like finally a little attention around
it yeah I mean we'll see I get stuff
like I ran away once when I was I think
12 and I spent the night at my friend's
fort and came back and extend you know I
was gone oh that's the kind of place I
was live at hilarious except they knew I
was gone
they had no idea I was gone I was in my
bedroom grounded and I just had had
enough and I just put on my winter coat
and everything and I walked out and they
go where you going I said see ya and I
shut the door and I went out into the
woods yeah hey how long there for four
or five hours I was gone yeah that's a
bad I think that's the I think but I
think I ran away from the house I didn't
run away I mean run away is you know
it's Joan Jett yeah but you know that's
the legal definition do you I mean you
must have felt alive living in that fort
living now he's living it out yeah
there also happen to me my friend also
happen to have a Dutch cousin staying
with him and she's gonna say a Dutch
oven in the [ __ ] for I mean we just
farted all night she'd know so there was
also having a big girl there that I was
attracted to so I was running away with
the idea in my heart but then I started
making out with her and I put my hand on
her and there's a lot of hair because
there's not a shaving situation back
then yeah and that was the end of that
hold on a second dormer I can ask where
your sexual knowledge was at that you
thought your first place to go would be
under the armpit I think I reached I
tried I was trying to get the bra yeah I
was try to get the bra I love I didn't
just go straight for the armpit that was
hot and sweaty her pheromones in there
just worried keep your [ __ ] do you have
a relationship in your father now not
really
is he still alive yeah he's still alive
and the last time I had a fight with him
like three years ago because he he saw
my he's now he's like total right-wing
no climate change like one of those
dudes wears when I was growing up he was
liberal and [ __ ] yeah he's wasted right
he flipped the switch but he looked at
my kid my kid had some some like eco
green shirt on I think and he just said
like then what are you gonna be one of
those liberal hippies would you climate
change and I just I just snapped and so
we had a big argument and it was like I
hadn't I even had a conversation with
him son so you didn't tackle him
I do not tackle him you should have do
you realize what's the hilarity like I
haven't talked to my dad in three years
man what was it like you know family
issues climate change
[ __ ] right there [ __ ] climate change
this mark argued three and a half hours
over Nepal and Everest you think there's
a drone took 45 minutes hour by place
yesterday that's um well we were just
screaming each other for a while about
everything and then and then my wife
just came down she was and my sister and
they're like you don't have a
relationship with him anymore see she
stopped talking to him
Wow she's like there's nothing there he
just wants to know this was at a it was
like a holiday or a family get-together
or something is your mom there too no it
was just my sister and her family and my
wife in your dad showed up yeah my dad
was there and so we got into it was
during the day and it was like two hours
we were yelling to each other does your
dad and sister have a relationship no
interesting so why did he show up was he
important I know but was he invited well
he invites himself so yes according to
him right yeah and then he shows up and
his his his girlfriend of 25 years is
barred from my sister's house she just
being a mean sits out in the car she
does she sits in the car hey I'm gonna
drive up there do you know I'll see when
I get back she just sits in the country
she just finds out she gets there like
oh I gotta sit out here maybe this thing
I don't love these people I'm just gonna
be here from yes he still drink oh yeah
yeah that's not stopping
he had down and she drives he had cancer
like six years ago and he had like three
quarters of his stomach removed and I
went up to see him and I walk in the
hospital room it's right after surgery
and he looks at me and he goes I could
still drink clear alcohol like those are
the first words that it was my office
all right so you're not stopping you're
gonna keep going so yeah he's still he's
yeah how old is he he's he's like 78 now
Wow and he's an attorney and he still
works I mean that's up there for the for
drinking for decades
oh yeah that's I think haze yeah that's
a that was to show you what he could
have done if he had could have been 160
who knows could have got the 160 years
old he didn't play in the NFL
tackle for sure we know that sure
tackler but when he's like when he's
like 85 I'm gonna tackle the process
it's so crazy though I think it's weird
that like even you know my dad passed
away a month ago no I had only seen him
once so you or not how did it but how
did it affect you if he passed away well
this is the thing so I was like 12 the
last time I saw him and then I saw him
six six years ago so I've seen him once
in 26 years yeah your dad loved you more
Dave yeah your mom's well yeah yeah yeah
like there was some emailing at
different points and we stopped and then
was two phone calls over the last 25
years you know stuff like that so when I
got the call I was in New York and I was
like I said my wife I'm like I'm going
home yeah there was no ceremony I went I
literally went got a hotel up near where
he lived
I went saw my aunt who I hadn't seen in
25 years and spent like I walked in the
house and she had a friend over and I'm
like how you doing she's like good and
I'm like good to see you she liked you
too she's really sweet and she goes you
want a drink I'm like no I'm all right
and she goes we're drinking jack on the
rocks I was like and then I spent this
all my buddies that night spent over
next day went to the antique store he
worked at hung out with his the people
that owned the shop and they start
telling me stories about my dad
yeah then I went to see his wife at her
house and talked to her and her son and
their friend and saw his workshop and
was there for like three hours then left
there they gave me a key to his
apartment I went to his apartment stood
in the spot that he died you know what I
mean and just took it all in and tried
to experience it told my wife I'm like I
just want that I want to end the story I
want to write the last chapter a little
bit and so it was you know I went
through some [ __ ] on my own I just kind
of wanted my own deal but it's funny
that after all that time that he had
nothing do with me I still had to go you
know anymore yeah there's a day he at
the end of the day still your dad and
whatever was there wasn't there it's a
weird thing and weird right agreed yeah
we'll see what happens when my dad kicks
it all Susan
a second second show right melon run in
Melbourne the newspapers down there like
when will Dave Anthony's dad oh it's
gonna be a great show
it's a funny thing as he just tracks me
on Twitter well this is weird thing I
know my dad does love me but he has no
capability of showing it yeah because he
he always tells other people what I'm
doing and he's never said a word to me
so it's just this bizarre so just that
would always create more anger and more
anger where he would tell her that
people are great I was doing it and then
never say a word to me yeah so it was
just this bizarre situation so so he
actually read like I got a reviewed in
The Herald Sun down there and a really
good review for stars but it broke down
what the show was about and so he read
it and sent me like a little terse email
like yeah I guess you finally made it
you're welcome yeah why could you get 5
stars you [ __ ] yeah then he probably
found that other [ __ ] review and had
her paid at the email at tea of writers
should you review about my son once an
email so that might have been him
actually writing rewriting the review
that's amazing yeah so I don't know it's
it's a Wasi when he dies we'll see how I
feel I don't know yeah it's a trippy
it's a trippy thing but he you know okay
so he would always he would always be
there in odd ways like he would be there
part of my sports stuff mm-hmm
when I wrote the pole I can hold on a
second when you say that all that
picture now is like you hitting like a
base hit to the gap and like rounding
second he's running with you he would he
would always be like an assistant coach
really and I hate it because he doesn't
want to be fully responsible yeah like a
dad in who's actually run the picket
fence on like this is baseball that just
set up for the picket fence goddamn but
what the whole infield is third-base
yeah the small head I know what I'm
gonna Bowl
and then it works we see wear jeans what
and literally yeah best pose now the
kids all wear pants yeah well they that
was a league that didn't provide you
pants my dad was like you're not [ __ ]
wearing jeans we would really we would
go to the sporting goods store and get
pants and then that's also where I
learned sanitary socks you probably know
those Jay Larson no sanitary saw or they
were that real thin white sock you were
under the store that was like you're
going out proper out there I tuck my
shirt in pull it oh yeah all right
no G I always looked at the kid G I want
to look at you and me like your dad
doesn't [ __ ] love because my kids
five I'm like driving all over LA go man
I got to find some goddamn short pants
my kid in wearing pants all the way down
to his shoes so my kids only gonna kid
out there with the you know the stirrup
show I love it there yeah they're always
I like the I like this yeah it's great I
hope it comes back because I don't like
what's happening out there right well
the Orioles are doing it right they are
nice well you know those all those guys
are wearing stirrups they just have them
super low right yeah the pant oh they
don't stretch them down all the way and
to like if you pull the pants all the
way up at the top of those stirrups have
the like the Red Sox have the red and
then there's like blue and white stripe
right at the top if you pull all the way
up yeah see when we were in college we
all wore soccer socks with our you knees
like solid blue
so our you knees were white with blue
and red blue letters and red numbers but
we wear blue matching socks and pull
them all the way up to our knees [ __ ]
dope dude I like to cut off sleeves to
like the rim the wear and the pirates
yeah yeah if you can't find baseball
pants go to a costume shop pirate pants
their same and a plaid shirt puffy shirt
and get out there get yourself some
pirate hat it turns into a thing where
every time your son gets up the fans
like
all right okay so so eyes I'm uh I'm ten
or eleven and I'm an angry kid and I've
written the play which went fabulously
by the way
well the reviews like that they were
smashing cuz I performed in front of the
whole school
you really did I really did a one man
one man wow they I know I had other care
cast so yeah it was I wrote a plan than
ever was in it what are you [ __ ]
Rushmore over here look man I had some
[ __ ] going on it's tough to get out that
emotions pouring out of me so I wrote a
play about an alien named Bleeker all
right everybody the poor kids got to
play baseball he's gonna play yeah so my
teacher comes to me and I'm the bad kid
in class right I'm the kid and they can
class it they have turned my desk to
face the wall cuz I'm just a knight
disruptive it yeah everything president
she was look you're very creative kid
wow there's there's a [ __ ] quit touch it
right under there so she says there
there's a class for kids who are
artistic you know they show artistic
tendencies not autistic like you were
thinking
I saw where your eyes were going now
we're gonna go right there waiting like
you get it you took it when I saw your
face so so I'm like yeah I'll do that
and then I didn't know what it was and
but right now I'm about to do this play
bit let's reconvene after my plate right
hold on the lights are dimming why are
you talking to me right now so on
Wednesdays I got to leave school at
lunch and I would go to this place so I
get there the first time but why I'm
Wednesday like only there was an
autistic school well there was just
there was they took a kid from every
sort of class
every school and sent them from the
district and sent them to this to the to
the Community College and there is and
you went there and you were they like
were like they're really trying to make
kids who could be artists you know more
tactical well it's not that cool because
I got there it was a mine there's a mime
class all he needs knows how to pull
rope and put them in a box I walk in and
now and I'm like what everyone's got to
be like me here like kind of like you're
on probation or whatever like it's no
one wants to be a mime right but they
all wanted to be mines like they're all
super into it and how is only one who is
like there's no your kid there's no like
mine you look up to all who likes black
tights and white facepaint
come on then yeah you're brave raise out
you see put on this white face which
about to get real it's about to get real
right now oh my god go well I'm the bad
kid right so I'm the kid II won't
participate and they're like you're in a
box put your hands up and be like ok I'm
in a box why don't you just help me out
of the box like it was just [ __ ] like
that was just a nightmare and you're
talking the whole time yeah I would talk
and they like and they like throw fake
you know throw the fake ball at you and
I'd be like I don't see it I just do
[ __ ] like that imagine if like this was
like a new way of like disciplining kids
would you fake beat them and [ __ ] but
but you're not just mind beat them Joe
Pesci I'm out in the desert so that goes
on for a while and then and then the
other moms just hated my guts
like the other mind kids hate my guts so
one day we we do we it's May
and they're all kids they're all kids
are all in like fifth and sixth grade
who's leading this class well there's a
FAQ oh you mean the teacher yeah I don't
remember it was some lady I remember the
fat kid I don't remember anybody else
what about the kid
so he's like this fat kid with a bowl
cut just the kind of kid you think we'd
get in a miming there's a lot of core
strengthener it is and he is uh and he
just hates me and he's always saying
stuff like just do it you know put your
hands up and this is how my dad
communicates to me so so one day it's
we're taking a break it's like a
three-hour class so we're taking a break
cuz faking [ __ ] is really hard and I'm
sitting there eating my Cheetos all and
all the minds walk up to me the whole
class is like 12 of them and and they've
all got their mouths like filled up like
they're like this well their cheeks all
puffy uh-huh
I'm looking at him and I'm like what's
up minds you know and then they all
they'd gone to the water fountain and
filled up their mouths with water and
this is did I say this is face paint day
so we'd all fade painted our faces
instead so they all spit water at me oh
and I'm just drenched with spit well -
spit oh and also like the fact that I've
just been picked on by mimes and quiet
all 12 you up right now my god oh no man
they hated you so you got bullied they
hate math boy tomorrow man
even the mimes rejected me that's how
[ __ ] up I was and queer but you see
the irony of it I mean irony if it's
irony but like how bold of a statement
they made they spit water out of their
unspeaking mouths yeah so wash away the
paint that makes you a mug
that's like some Dostoevsky it gets
worse because they didn't wash off the
paint and what happened was these colors
don't run never can it never came off
man never came off until I had surgery
Friday so I don't go back to the class
and I just sit down anyway for my dad to
pick me up because he's coming to pick
me up cuz I have a baseball game take
your beret off catch it catch it got
better so gotta break so now it's been
like two hours since I got attacked by
the other mimes that I've been sitting
there waiting and and I totally
forgotten that I had face paint off and
you just took it though I want to ask
you about that you just took that you
didn't yeah yeah it was so I mean I
think I yelled at him but it was so
shocking and they're also 12 of them
right and the big one pushed me a little
bit and I just didn't know what to do
was just like what the okay it was also
like when you think so little of people
and then they attack you it's such a
weird thing because I was huge I was I
still was I was weighted athlete and I
was and I was still like one of the
higher kids in my class as far as being
like normal and cool but but then you're
getting attacked by people that you
think are morons
yeah it's been the start of the Juggalos
like you ever won to quit a job and you
get fired yes yeah so so he picks me up
and it's the situation where we're gonna
be late for the game and so I'm changing
in the backseat of the car and at no
point is he like you want to take off
that my makeup cuz I had totally
forgotten it was on he just doesn't say
he just doesn't say a word and so they
get to the game
you probably didn't even notice he's
wasted finally look like err bio now so
let's show up and the game is like about
to start and and someone's like what's
what's up with your face and I was like
oh my god I have my makeup on and then
the game starting and I didn't and there
was no part of me that was like just go
wash it off cuz I was like up second or
something so I'm like I gotta stay here
and do this and I go out there and I
start playing and I get hit the first
kid of course I told this story in
Australia and and no one understood that
but yeah of course Americans are like
yeah of course you got hit I would've
hit you - like that's baseball you get
to commute at the mind get the minds out
there and snot listen me see that mine
coming up to bat put him on first base
let's watch and then I was just getting
picked on by everybody my team team like
a normal dad would have been like hey
man pull the kid aside and go like don't
take off the my makeup do you want to do
you want to leave first like a normal
dad like get your ass over here and get
that off ya know I'd be like you're not
going to mime school I don't know what
you're thinking but it's not happening
even surprising he didn't though you
know what I mean like all the anger I
had and [ __ ] you would think you'd be
like get that [ __ ] off your face
right yeah he just that maybe am I'm so
uh what was that might have been the one
day your mom was like just be supportive
i don't think i'm santi your dad didn't
have anything right yeah yeah yeah oh we
did about to find out cuz then here so
this is what this is what like
alcoholics and arses do it's all about
them so instead of like taking care of
me he it becomes about Hamlet he seaming
it picked off so he gets into a fight
with the other coach and it was like it
was like the step it was like the the
70's type of you know
yeah [ __ ] that went on where the coaches
like Bad News Bears where the coaches
would actually get out there and I can't
I remember so many games where the
coaches would be pushing each other and
doing it so that went on and it was just
like I just sitting there like you go
hey man I'm a mind what about me
you don't look sad I gotta tell you're
not doing good guy you've got a smile
painted on so yeah so that's how it
ended you jagged off fight with the yeah
and then you drive home with the make oh
I think I feel like that was also the
game where he got key got kicked out and
and sent so right outside the
centerfield fence was a little hill and
I think this was the game where he got
kicked out and went and sat on the hill
and watched through the game so I would
be sitting there at bat like just like
trying to hit and my drunk dad's like
just watch him his arms folded like just
I gotta be honest with you though at
least the my makeup helped him
understand when you were bad I just
started pretending like I was hitting
home bro do you struck out you struck
out I'm like no I didn't I put that over
the good I want you to love do it if you
struck out kept going running dude if a
joke about everybody else all right this
is angry that was your next play this is
angry I got it so my at one point I
wanted to quit baseball because I hated
the team I was on I'm sure was all but
just have to say that moment right there
this is actually years later so this is
what I'm like honestly 14 or now 13 so
it's like a couple years later I did
want to be on this team anymore I
thought the kids are [ __ ] I just
want to play and my dad goes we used you
started playing so you have to play and
I'm like well they're picking on me and
it's [ __ ] and I don't want to be
here he goes you this is a commitment
you made I'm like okay so I would go up
to bat and strike out on purpose
oh so they are in land and they're
swinging I would swing and drag on
purpose and then I would turn around to
the opposing fans
grandstand and raise my bad over my head
and be like yeah
and that went on for like half a season
and he never pulled me from the he never
he didn't have the power he's working
something out he'll be all right like
that's crazy
where's our third-base coach he's over
in the car taking an it real quick I
can't imagine seeing that as an adult
now watch watching it now I'd be like
holy [ __ ] someone I'll tell you man I
can't ever egg the idea to even think
about doing that when I was like knowing
who I was growing up yeah like I
couldn't even imagine to have my head
wrapped around a commitment towards
rebellion like that I was insane it was
all about just like [ __ ] you dad that's
all it was we should do your mother come
to games to know yeah my mom is like
she's never seen me do stand-up like
she's never really yeah she's just she
was actually in Australia she happen to
be there the same time taking a vacation
did you start Cisco yeah yeah and she
never went to him Jennifer came to her
show has your dad been new show
Wow okay so there's a one time I was
living in New York dads who drink them
no problem so I was living in New York
and I and this is when we just had
beepers and and I was sitting at home
and he used to beat me and be like hey
give me a call and I'm sitting in my
house and the phone doesn't ring and all
of a sudden he beeps me and I'm like
that [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] is making me
call him long-distance cuz he doesn't
want to make the call and pay for it so
I was sitting there I was like I'm gonna
wait until he calls me three years three
years ago by three years ago pages are
out at this that's not like it's not
like I was mad at I'm done right it's
not as mad at him I just said I'll wait
until he calls me and I'm getting calm
some new technology I'm getting calls
from my uncles and my grandmother who
are like call your father and I'm like
he can just call me he's never called me
and they're like we'll just call him I'm
like why doesn't he call me and three
years go by so I haven't talked to this
guy for three years and I'm working at
the punch line in San Francisco and I
walk in the front door and they go hey
man your dad's here yeah dude I want to
throw a table out the window I was like
and I just looked at him and I said kick
him out shut um they were like what and
I go get him out of here I'm not going
onstage Wow
so they walked over to him and they're
sure if he just called me up and said
hey I'm coming down to the show you want
to talk afterwards or anything any
communication or just go yeah I would
have let him stay there but you just
don't show up up you haven't talked to
someone for three years yes I had him I
had him booted
I just sent it from the back watching as
they liked that he's never and I don't
say I don't think he saw me
because you know they're facing forward
so I came in in and when I think I went
behind the bar to watch and I just
remember them walking over to whispered
to him and what's been so awkward for
that staff yeah [ __ ] but that's he's
he sat down he was like yeah there's my
kid and start telling everyone around
him I got two more drinks coming the
minimum this morning I mean literally
I'm feeling pain in my chest that's a
little heartbreaking I mean is but as
much as a dick and drunk that he was
could you imagine being there like and
then getting getting bounced like no
you're getting kicked out why your son
doesn't want you here yeah whoo yeah how
did he go quietly yeah he went quietly
by himself or was it he was with our old
friend or the Carmen she's
she was like that was short he went
outside wall he's like almost leadership
he keeps her chained in the car not
allowed to get out so then after that
when the next time you talked well then
then I had so then if he ever address it
with you yeah I don't think we ever
talked about it he never brought it up
either I don't think you ever brought me
thrown out of the club I would
definitely bring that up it's hilarious
so then like years maybe four years
later three years later I just had like
I just got a I got a kind of I went to
therapy and I was like I got a cop to my
side of things yeah so I went and talked
to my mom and was like this is all that
[ __ ] I did you know on my end I'm sorry
and I went to my dad and I just I don't
think I apologize to him but I was like
all right so you know this is the deal
and this is where we're at and I should
have cut the lawn listen I understand
and he said I remember the thing he said
to me he goes he didn't he didn't say
anything that would you know no
emotional stuff he just said I have a
little monster inside of me Wow Wow Wow
I keep under control pour whiskey on
them especially if it's clear you know
what I mean but I heard I heard later
that a lot of alcoholics say that they
little Mulford yeah that's like a common
friend so that's the thing they're
taught to say I have a little monster
inside of me dude and then they reach
into their [ __ ] and they pull out a
piece of [ __ ] and they go this is it
this is I need to be in a hospital it's
great man that's great
Wow before we got a talking on my cue it
dropped a couple of things I definitely
want to hear this Halloween story okay
now so now that we know all about you
and where you grew up I want to hear
this house that's a super white white
white white white place then I'm in high
school when I go to a Catholic High
School and I think we had one black kid
there all-boys school no okay no but we
had one black kid there I think we've
recruited to be on the football team in
favor if it's a private school if I
recall correctly we used to have like
Masco or something would be like bused
in from the city go out to like what
something like that yeah yeah it's
something we'd have at our school but
there are other towns writers that had
them yeah so I'm a huge fan Eddie Murphy
a huge fan and I especially a huge fan
of the was a character said I like
buckwheat was that it yeah yeah yeah I'm
a huge fan of that are you watching SNL
it's six yeah so Halloween comes how you
doing I just got it so I mean now
whenever I see pictures of this I like
these guys do this and I go yeah I get
it so I have no idea this is wrong and I
decided to be buckwheat but not white
buck we don't know so so ice I have
curly hair so I spray it
I like brush it up so it's like just it
looks like big nappy hair and I paint it
black and then I put on blackface
how old is way too old I'm 15 would your
dad say no one said anything so here's
the best part you've painted your face
white and black like that and said
that's right that's why I feel like you
should get some slack he's like well you
know he was white paint away yours I'll
be why
right now pink now flash white that's
how white it was pronounce the H well so
because it says white community no one
bats an eye
I mean nobody bats a [ __ ] eye like no
one's like what do you do I go over to
my friends house before we cuz cuz we
get drunk and do blow before we go to
this this there's a dance at the school
and all my friends are like man it's
just amazing how much look no one even
the kids parents at house right they're
not like what are you doing no one says
a word to me that it's insane yeah and
so I were we're and they just keep going
man you look great great John the
baggage and then we go to this dance it
won best costume and we go to this dance
like well okay God gods okay so you go
to the dance at the school and they have
they have a costume contest and I'm just
standing there as they're not seeing the
winners thinking I got this and the guy
it's like a DJ guy he announces the
winner and I'm like what but hang on and
I walk up to the most racist
I walk up to the DJ my dad put you up to
this this is what I said
dude this is a costume I'm not black oh
my god because I know I saw your hands
and he looks at me with like is he a
white guy he's a white guy but he has
like this just look on his face and he
looks at me he goes oh I know
we're just anywhere in any town but the
town I'm in yeah he just lifts anywhere
else and so then it gets worse so then
the dance ends and someone's like hey
man there's a party in San Rafael
now San Rafael is the only city in Marin
that has diversity good good choice okay
and throw in a pissed-off white
buckwheat so we go to this party in San
Rafael and there's a lot of black guys
there and they're looking at me like
they're gonna [ __ ] kill me and I'm
like I don't know what's happenin [ __ ]
you say you rushin above a line like
okay man okay I was doing that all night
of course I was doing all the lines it's
so horrifying so uh so I am walking on
this party and I said something to some
black David and he goes you need to not
talk to me and you need to get the [ __ ]
away from me and I was like what is
happening man like I had no [ __ ] clue
put it together
I absolutely no clue that this was
something that could be wrong and then I
proceeded to get shit-faced
Oh like just plowed out of my mind to
the point that I wanted off to go throw
up and I fell asleep in a yard vomited
past passed out woke up being arrested
by the cops I've got a weird-looking
black
my guys there we are don't arrest me I'm
a little white guy so you got that kid
is on that ship paint house with bags
well [ __ ] is that the mom so you're what
14 15 15 and you're arrested I'm all
right what's the charge
well so the black people were pissed and
now at this point you know a lot of it's
wiped off it just looks ridiculous so my
makeup will stand it's a black mag so
this is a time when they don't you know
they a lot of cops would just call your
parents yeah and that was it so they
call my mom my mom we thought he looked
good my mom walks home no as Raggedy Ann
and Andy you people well she didn't know
that I don't think she knew I was in
blackface until she walked in and she
was just like oh my god what is
happening and I just remember I remember
being in the police station just waiting
for her to pick me up and just the cops
just walking by I mean look at me going
holy [ __ ] yeah how how did we not shoot
you yeah and that yeah that my mom just
came to pick me up and she's like what
did you do am I gonna had a night man
it's hard being a black
he's been black the red man or San
Rafael or period oh so now whenever I
see those pictures that pop up like
every couple of years on the internet
this fraternity did a blackface night I
just go you should go like around the
country and do speaking engagements on
that [ __ ] you can't stop that when you
grew up in a white place you just don't
know yeah literally have no idea I mean
I don't know you know I don't know we
were so [ __ ] situation sheltered we
were so sheltered man we had no look
when I was in elementary school sixth
grade we lived at a place called Sleepy
Hollow yep as that time yeah so it's
just crazy sounds legendary easy white
and our junior high school was supposed
to be in Sleepy Hollow but then they
passed this thing called prop 13 and
they had closed a bunch of schools so we
had to go into town a few miles away to
go to junior high school and I mer was
sitting in class and people were crying
kids were crying at one area and one
girl stood up and said I think there's
black people at that school oh my god
that's the kind of place I was from okay
that's why you probably could've gone to
the store and bought the buckwheat cop
kit okay mommy before I get it just got
it off the shelf and that yeah but now
here's the worst thing was that we
actually had we were friends with like
maybe the one black family my dad when
he got divorced he got remarried to a
woman who was friends with this this
black family and so I actually knew a
black family and so to me when someone
said that I was like well that's [ __ ]
crazy but it still didn't ever register
to me to not put on blackface yeah
here's another great story is when I got
a dog I named it was a white dogs I
named it honky uh-huh
that's good call how are you I was at 11
and then and then but did you go and we
have a dog what did you get the daughter
to your mom get it me and my dad my dad
got it and then when when we went on my
dad we went on vacation the black family
took care of the dog and they so what
I'm saying is is that I totally I
totally understand what's happening in
Baltimore that's my point a way to bring
that full circle
yeah so oh yeah
we a tweet look it this is so I'm having
so much fun we have a little more time I
want to hear about this I mean
motorcycles okay
now let me just say if people can change
and I'm totally normal you have can well
I would honestly people wouldn't even
share that and I've had a great time but
you know I saw when you pulled up that
bumper sticker that no blacks is good
black and I think that's that's his mama
stick you know I just thought I just
about coffee it's a coffee
Thomas do ya know obviously people can
change I think that's a you know I
wouldn't tell that story if I hadn't yes
hinder anything you know you clearly see
how [ __ ] up it was people people grow
up in the craziest [ __ ] so you just
don't know what they're gonna become you
know for sure so when I moved here I was
[ __ ] crazy angry so like about two to
two thousand I move here and I'm just
you go to college
yeah I went to UC Santa Barbara to
college I lived in New York for five
years doing stand-up came out here and
I'm on the highway
and it's the 10 so it's just a parking
lot on a Friday no one's moving and I'm
in the fast lane and I'm like I want to
get off the highway so I start like I
look in the mirror and I start inching
over to try to get in the other Lane and
I hear this someone banging on the back
of my car just like just then I turn
around and dude on a motorcycle then
he's like you [ __ ] cut me off you saw
him a [ __ ] and I was like I didn't see
you and I gave him the wave you know the
old I'm sorry I almost killed him yeah
yeah my bad man
there's the wave so we're good right it
pulls her on the side of me you drive
her side now mm-hmm you're in the fast
lane to steal a shoulder or swap oh he's
right up against the the Jersey thing
yeah and he starts punching me in the
face come on yes he pulls up on Sammy
stops the motorcycle because the where
to stop traffic oh okay he just starts
hitting me and so and so now because I'm
so angry
I can't handle anybody getting anything
over on me
like it's just not gonna [ __ ] happen
like you just don't get to do any first
of all this isn't getting over on this
guy's beating you up a little salt right
put and why I keep a knife but a normal
person would get his I do too I do for
[ __ ] like that if that ever happens to
me I'm rolling when though that's
exactly right come to the face all day I
completely agree so so I another person
would grab his license plate or whatever
and write it down and go this guy salted
me but he starts driving away so I just
turned my car yeah and took him down
just [ __ ] knocked him down so he
it's the he brought a motorcycle took
car fight right yeah so yeah so he hits
the he hits the center thing and then he
just splays out on the ground and I'm
sitting there I'm like let me just run
over there's just all these cars around
I'm like that's a [ __ ] felony like
I'm that's jail [ __ ] that's self-defense
no it's good attorney yeah well okay so
so I look
I'm like I got to get out of you know I
know a good attorney yeah oh yeah yeah I
mean he actually got kicked out of court
about five years ago because he was too
drunk Oh
the judge was like mr. Anthony have you
been drinking at lunch and he said I
just had to
all right we're adjourned till tomorrow
so Wow uh-huh and they his his client
was like oh [ __ ] I'm going to jail
so so I look to my right across the four
lanes and all of a sudden the cars just
parted like it opened up a lane for me
and I made a right turn on the highway
and just went across all the lanes to
the shoulder and then just shot down the
shoulder and I'm like [ __ ] yeah I just
got away with this [ __ ] I just hate this
and I'm like oh my cousin's so many
people saw that this is now a
hit-and-run yeah and I'm going to jail
like this is [ __ ] up and I started
shaking and I was just completely
freaked out so I decided to call the
cops I'm like I have to call the cops
and tell them and just say I was scared
of this guy he attacked me and then I
was scared he's gonna get the [ __ ] up
and climb on my windshield and exactly
make some chests awesome chain on his
bike eyes blurry look like change you
get away with [ __ ] like I couldn't see
well my my mind paint was running in the
other eye because it's fun you know I
had my face on one side it's all
thinking very confused so I pull off and
I go to a boil logo the crazy chick
mm-hmm
and I call the cops in the parking lot
and I'm sitting there and they're like
all right we'll send a car out and I'm
just like panicked just for a half-hour
I'm like I'm going to jail like I'm
really going to jail this time like this
is no [ __ ] so I get a number set and I
walk up I go how crazy is your chick
again
well here's something great so uh so the
Highway Patrol comes and he goes why
don't you tell me what happened and I
said well I was I was minding my own
business
I don't know what why this guy was mad
but he started punching me in the face
and because he was punching me in the
face
it made me turn the wheel because he was
hitting me call Yeah right yeah thanks
man see the angry guy gets it you're
looking like dude I'm more angry than
anyone I would've been like [ __ ] I
had a match he would have you two hung
himself so now I had no problem saying
this guy I checked my mirrors probably
the day I thought I cut him off he
started beating my car yeah I apologized
I thought that was the end of it guard
down all of a sudden up alongside me
assaulting me punching my face but you
just can't admit that you hit him and he
was driving away I wouldn't have said
that I was said and then I and then
what'd you say and then I veered into
him that's that's what I said so so I
said you know because he was hitting me
I I was trying to duck down I turn the
wheel and then he goes well look we sent
a car by and there's nobody there
there's no guy on a motorcycle there's
no sign of an accident and nobody called
it it so so all these [ __ ] people saw
me we saw it [ __ ] he must have seen him
punching me and then when I did then
nobody called it in everyone was like
yeah that was cool what if it never
happened nobody on the ten right now
it's moving right along I don't know
what he's talking about
made it downtown in 15 minutes sometimes
I also see dragons okay all right so so
he says so he says yes and nobody called
it in in the guy didn't call it in but
you did so you're you did what your due
diligence you did with Union the story
is what you say it is right right now
that's the story he goes so you're in
the clear and I was like what does that
even mean and he said well the guy was
probably an illegal immigrant
uh-huh I was like yeah that's the old
way I could get away with it yeah I was
hitting a poor guy or also and I know
this because my brother had a situation
like this he may currently be on
probation or a warrant that's right and
then [ __ ] even gets anything reports at
least that today I didn't think about
that because I've got a guy who pulls up
and starts punching someone in the face
has probably done some other [ __ ]
probably for coffee you guys might hit
it off well I'll tell you this is this
has been a great episode this has been
so much fun my phrase [ __ ] hurts
thank you for Kyler Lanier's yeah I lost
all all my black fans yeah they're gone
I mean I want to thank you I also want
to thank you dad because if it wasn't
for him any of this well that's the
weird thing like I wouldn't be a
stand-up you know I wouldn't have this
career yeah he did he told you yeah
you're welcome
what do you one more time please plug
promote anything you'd like social media
your shows any of that stuff I have an
album the iTunes or band camp or
whatever
I think it's on Spotify too but you
don't want to do that because we'd only
make money from that but it's called
shame chamber Dave Anthony shame chamber
I have my podcast with Gareth Reynolds
who is [ __ ] hilarious
very funny dude also an atc podcast yep
it's called the dollop and I just tell I
just read him one story from American
history crazy stories and he's never
heard it and he just reacts to it it's I
have a lot of fun doing it and then
sounds like fun it's great and then I
I'm not I have no gigs right now because
I'm after the crazy six months I've had
him taking a long time off well you're
also prepping for LA podcast festival
yeah we're doing that we're getting
ready for that that is going to be
September 18th and 17th and 18th and in
here in Beverly Hills you can go to LA
pop fest calm and it's great we've been
there if you guys are there last year we
go yes so what's right we'll be there
this year
well and that's you know
le podcasting it wasn't that great last
year but just opening night in the big
room with ie [ __ ] out that's all I'm at
at Dave Anthony on Twitter awesome and
there's a lot of fun thing I'm glad we
were able to make this route so glad I
finally got it in here we're trying for
like a year I mean we were guests made
babies we were hearted about that for I
mean we really meant it for the last two
or three months you know yeah so I kind
of wanted it like your dad guy as always
Jay Larson comedy Facebook Twitter
Instagram Pinterest Jay Larson calm be
calm Ryan Sickler on Instagram Twitter
and Facebook Ryan Sickler calm we'll
talk to you all next Tuesday